ah why hello there viewer I am reloading
Santos quest I reloaded Anna's quest the
way it was originally done I'm not
editing or changing it or like
remastering it at all
and I'm kind of doing your for posterity
sake because it's a classic video series
that I did on my channel like originally
might like Thanos quest Infinity
Gauntlet like those are what really
helped to blow up my channel that in
Civil War and I don't want to change
those so keep in mind these are videos
made from like four years ago rob was a
little different back then
so the Thanos quest is an essential read
for anybody looking to get into the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline and
especially with the current set of
events that we see in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now there's a couple
reasons for this the first reason is
because this gives us an introduction to
how it is that Thanos gains the infinity
gems and we'll see that as the comic
progresses we'll first see them
described as the soul gems and then
we'll see that us change the name
effectively to infinity Jim but the
other reason why this is very important
is because this story that we see the
Thanos quest is in effect what we see
going on in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe at this moment it's going on in
the background it's not necessarily a
main front storyline like what we see
going on here with this uh this jim
Starlin run but this is an effect what's
going on in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Thanos is going on a quest to
track down the infinity gems
now what we'll see is that as the story
progresses individuals that that hold
the infinity gems are simply individuals
that we just haven't been introduced to
yet in the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
we may never be introduced to them of
course we'll see for example that the
possessor of the power gym and the
Thanos quest storyline is vastly
different than the possessor of the
power gem in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but the basis for this remains
the same Thanos is simply just tracking
down the infinity gems and attempting to
use them for the task of eliminating
half the life in the universe now what
we see going on here as the story picks
up is that we don't know that OSes
assigned the task of eliminating half of
life in the universe all we see here is
that Thanos is peering into the Infinity
well now of course if you remember our
discussion we we had talked about the
Adam warlock and the infinity watch and
so on and so forth we had mentioned the
infinity well and we said that the
infinity well is a source of infinite
knowledge but the problem here is that
it's only a source of infinite knowledge
for people who are able to ask the right
questions and so it's not as those you
can simply just peer into it and know
everything about everything what we see
is that one of the servants of mistress
death arrives and this servant speaking
on behalf of mistress desk asks Thanos
why it is that he's not fulfilled the
the assignment that was given to him by
mistress death that the universe as he
says it awaits death gentle touch what
we also see is that a Thanos tells this
servant that he is peering into the
infinity well to find an answer on how
to achieve this he's finding an answer
on how to achieve the goal that mistress
death has given him now of course again
we don't know exactly what this is but
then what we see is that he has brought
towards or brought in front of mistress
death and mistress death again with one
of her servants asks Thanos the question
why it is he hasn't done this yet of
course we see that Thanos replies by by
simply saying is it really necessary
that his faith and his servitude to
mistress death be questioned that
everything he's done has been done in a
way to serve mistress death faithfully
and that for him it seems kind of an
insult that they would come along and
ask the question why have you not
fulfilled this task what we also see is
that the task that has been laid before
mr. Zorba for Thanos by mistress death
is to eliminate half the life in the
universe but with Thanos the problem
here is that it would take several
lifetimes
even his lifetimes despite the fact that
he is an extremely powerful being it
would take quite some time in order for
him to achieve this task given the
powers that he has at the moment because
the size of the universe is absolutely
massive and even the life within it is
teeming there are quite a number of
species and individuals and so on that
are alive within the universe and so to
simply eradicate half of them is
something that is for the most part
almost impossible we then see that
Thanos says that in looking in the
Infinity well he has learned of a source
of power that could allow him to
expediate this process that could allow
him to eliminate half the life in the
universe in an extremely fast amount
time in addition he goes as far as to
say that it will augment his powers it
will give him more powers and so again
this will tie into the element of him
being able to do this in a much faster
pace but then we see that when
clarification is asked that when more
information is asked on behalf of
mistress death in terms of what these
items are Thanos reveals to us the soul
gems and this is when we learn about the
basis of these gems although what we'll
see as time progresses and each gem is
captured is that each gem has a power
unto its own and bad does that a
description of that power will be given
to us by Thanos what we see is that
Thanos says that the problem here with
these gems is that they're wielded by
various individuals in fact with six
gems they're wielded by six individuals
but the individuals who wield them don't
know their power a lot of the
individuals that wheel them simply view
them as trinkets or talismans of some
kind but they don't actually know the
basis behind them and that if Thanos is
able to wield all six of these infinity
gems are these soul gems that he can use
them for the purpose of eliminating all
life in the universe for the benefit of
a mistress death what we also see is
that us asking permission to seek out
these soul gems and he tells mistress
death that the first person he intends
to go after is the in-betweener
from here we see that Thanos is granted
permission by mistress death to to go
under the I guess to fulfill the quest
of capturing these six soul gems and of
course we see that us making heading
towards his goal which is the location
of the in-betweener
at this point we learned where it is the
in-betweener is at and the in-betweener
is actually between dimensions he is
between the pulling I guess the the
forces of Master Order and Lord chaos
and this makes sense just because the
in-betweener was created as a go-between
for master order and lord chaos but also
as a way to represent the opposing
forces a chaos and order within the
universe and of course neither of these
forces can ever have any more power than
the other because it would cause the
universe to bend in the favor of
whichever individual is more powerful
and the universe has to exist within the
balance or with a balance of order and
chaos
at this point we find out that what had
gone on here is that the in-betweener at
some point along the line had
effectively I guess gone beyond the the
role that was given to him he had for
some reason or another or in some some
method angered master order and Lord
chaos and so as a result they have
imprisoned him in between the opposing
forces of master order and Lord chaos
within a bubble within a sphere that he
cannot penetrate we also see that on
this chunk of land there are various
individuals various organisms or aliens
that were placed there by master order
and Lord chaos to ensure that that the
in-betweener cannot escape or that
nobody can can effectively break in and
save him but the problem here is that
when they were created when these uh
these creatures were made the concept of
Thanos being as powerful as he is was
never considered and so what we see is
that Thanos is able to completely
eradicate all these forces that are
there to to guard the in-betweener at
this point we see the in-betweener and
Thanos engaging in a conversation and I
would like you to pay very close
attention here because this is the way
the Thanos is going to capture the
infinity gems Thanos is in effect going
to manipulate various individuals in
order to steal their Jim and the first
person and I think probably the best
manipulated person is the is the
in-betweener what we see going on here
is that Thanos approaches the
in-betweener and tells the in-betweener
that he laments serving mistress death
that in the service of mistress death he
has come he has come to a point where he
simply just has a distaste for it and
that he wants to leave mistress death
but the problem is that he cannot leave
their service or leave her service
without invoking her ire which may very
well result in his own demise and that
his goal here is to free the
in-betweener and then enter the service
of the in-betweener who in turn will be
able to protect vanish from mistress
death The Inbetweeners a little
skeptical here but the issue is that of
course Thanos has his own goals and the
in-betweener believing that Thanos is it
is actually wanting to enter his service
also suspect there may be some kind of
ulterior motive we of course see that at
this point The Inbetweeners simply wants
to use Thanos as motivation to leave
mistress death and enter his own service
as a means to escape his prison and so
the in-betweener agrees what we see is
that
in the in-betweener used their own
abilities we see tennis attacking the
sphere from without and the in-betweener
attacking the sphere from within and
both of them are able to in effect
completely destroy the prison at this
point we see that the in-betweener sees
Thanos for what he is
he calls Thanos a liar calls him a a
traitor and we see that when the
in-betweener
attempts to use his power on Thanos that
nothing happens and we see that OSA in
effect overpower the in-betweener
and Thanos tells the in-betweener that
the only reason why he came was to take
his soul Jim to take the Jim from off of
his head what we also see going on is
that the in-betweener is confused as to
how his powers worked as to Wyatt as his
powers are not working now despite the
fact that they worked within the sphere
we see that us explained to the
in-betweener that this was done
intentionally by master order and Lord
chaos as a way for the in-betweener to
serve out his term his most likely
eternal imprisonment without being in
such a place where he would be unable to
use his powers this was more or less
than just being merciful on him and that
outside of any sort of real dimension
outside or I guess in a place where the
opposing forces of order and chaos mean
that his powers are canceled out and so
as a result he's powerless and so what
we see is that Thanos tells the
in-betweener
that he can't be sensed by master order
and Lord chaos and there are a little
there are some reasons behind this look
we're not going to go too far into it if
you aren't interested in that of course
you can find that in a video that we did
about Thanos proper but we say that
Thanos sort of taunting in-betweener and
tells the in-betweener that because
master order and lord chaos can't sense
him they don't know that he was there to
help break the in-betweener out of his
prison but because of the fact that the
prison was was created by master order
and lord chaos they are going to be
aware that the in-betweener is free from
his binds and that most likely the
prison they're going to put him in is
now going to be much less merciful than
the prison that he was freed from at
this point of course we see that master
order and lord chaos appear and while
the in-betweener pleads and tells master
order and lord chaos that it wasn't
necessarily his fault that Thanos was
the one that freed him
that off panel or I guess outside of our
ability to see that he's most likely
subjected to a new form of imprisonment
at this point we see fan OSA began to
sort of a focus or to ponder this new
Infiniti Jim the first of the six
Infinity Jim's and we see him say that
at one point this had belonged to Adam
warlock and that this infinity Jim is
the soul Jim this is the Jim that allows
the wielder to manipulate and to ensnare
the souls of other people at this point
we see that mistress death and one of
her servants arrived and of course again
the servants speaking on behalf of
mistress death ask nanos if he truly
laments his service to mistress death we
see that Thanos say that this was simply
just a ruse that it was it was simply
said to trick the in-betweener into
allowing Thanos to help him escape his
imprisonment and then allow Thanos to
capture his soul Jim we see that as this
explanation is given that Thanos says
that his word is his bond that he has
always served mistress death faithfully
and there's no reason for her to
question his faith even even at this
point we see that mistress death is
satisfied with his explanation and she
and her servant leave and then Thanos
again continues to ponder under these
circumstances and come to the conclusion
that while he had expected to mistress
death to spy on him he didn't you wasn't
really sure if it would actually happen
or not but that this confirms that they
are watching him and so we see that
oasw's revealed to us that he has an
ulterior plan although at this point we
don't really know what it is from here
we're gonna go ahead and bring the video
to an end and in the next video we're
gonna pick up with the second soul gym
where Thanos travels to a planet called
tamata where he fights a being known as
the champion an elder of the universe
who wields the power Jim with that being
said I will catch you guys in the next
video peace
[Music]
[Music]
so as we continue our discussion on the
infinity quest we pick up with the
acquisition of the power gym at the
hands of Thanos against the foe the
champion and what we see going on here
is that Thanos has arrived at the planet
Tama Huata Anna Stannis explains it to
us Tamara is a planet which has is a
strategic location for five different
warring factions and that because it's
such a strategic location this planet is
in effect a war zone
this planet is constantly being
conquered by one of the five factions
and then reconquered by another of the
five factions and what we see is that
the champion who is an elder of the
universe and wields the power Jim calls
this places home and the reason why is
because there's always conflict there's
always the ability for him to test his
prowess because the champion lives for
combat what we see is that the champion
for the most part is simply just tearing
away at the landscape tearing away
against various enemies and all this
really does is give us an idea of where
he stands in terms of his capabilities
and his powers but what we also see is
that Thanos gives us an explanation on
the the stance or where it is of the
champion stands in the grand scheme of
the Marvel Universe and what we learn
here is that by wielding the power Jim
the champion has become one of the
foremost foes within the Marvel Universe
one of the strongest individuals but
that he never really knows or he never
actually knows what's going on with his
Jim he doesn't realize that the the
power Jim gives him near infinite an
infinite source of physical energy the
ability to manipulate the energy Zenda
sheer physical strength and so what we
see as as the story progresses is that
Thanos arrives on at hamurana and
confronts the champion now one thing I
would like you guys to pay very close
attention here is that again what we
will see is that Thanos is able to
manipulate his opponent and this I think
is one of the most interesting
attributes of Thanos a lot of people
look at pharaohs and view him as some
sort of extremely powerful and
some sort of being who has vast energy
manipulating powers and physical
strength but doesn't view him as someone
who is extremely smart when in fact that
is very much the case while Thanos has a
vast array of powers at his disposal his
most formidable weapon is his mind
it's his intellect and his ability to
think strategically and so what we see
is that Thanos arrives and Thanos tells
champion that he has arrived on this
planet seeking a challenge seeking
someone worthy of facing him and the
champion tells him that on this planet
Thanos will only find a feat because the
champion is invincible he is the
strongest there is
and so what we see is that Thanos and
the champion begin to engage in combat
and almost immediately
Thanos is able to to demonstrate to us
that he's capable of not necessarily
physically overpowering the champion but
at the very least out thanking him and
this is one of the drawbacks this is one
of the inherent flaws of the champion
the champion as Stannis will explain to
us over the course of this comic book
relies too much on his physical power he
he doesn't think enough basically and so
because of this any opponent that he
goes against who is or who has any real
measure of intellect is going to be able
to outthink him
and is going to be able to to easily
outmaneuver him and effectively beat him
simply just by using his mind now the
conflict for the most part isn't that
incredible of a conflict it's really not
that amazing for the most part we just
sees Thanos fighting the champion and
engaging the champion in combat and over
time making the champion angrier and
angrier and this is one thing that fan
oohs takes a note of that fact that the
champion is very similar to the
Incredible Hulk in terms of how he
develops or how he gains his power that
the angrier he gets the stronger he gets
but again unlike the Incredible Hulk the
power that the champion has is drawn
from the power gym on his forehead and
not from anything due to his actual
physiology what we also see is that as
this as the story progresses as his
conflict continues on that eventually
the champion in an enraged state falls
right into the trap that Thanos had set
and this trap was the champion jumping
into the sky coming back down and then
destroying the planet tamarod ax
and the reason why this was a trap that
Thanos had set is because Thanos wanted
this to be done he wanted the champion
to destroy the planet and the reason for
this is because the power Jim allows the
champion to manipulate it his energies
but the champion is only able to
manipulate its energies and then in the
form of physical strength and so the
champion can't fly and this is what we
see that was telling the champion this
is what we see him communicating to him
as he begins to taunt him that the
problem here is that while the champion
is immortal while he's an elder of the
universe and that he can't die he can't
go anywhere
and so he's effectively just floating in
endless space forever we see the Thanos
I'm sorry that the champion says that
he'll battle Thanos for his vessel and
and tano simply says no there's no
reason for him to that there's really
nothing worth fighting over anymore and
this again is simply just Thanos baiting
the champion what we then see is the
champion pleading with Thanos saying the
Thanos can't simply just leave him there
that'll threw pies by again telling the
champion that that he's immortal that
the vacuum of space won't kill him and
that maybe in a few centuries somebody
will arrive to take him somewhere else
we then see that that the champion
continues to plead and thatö says that
he will move him he will take him to
another location
but only for a price and when the
champion asks him what that price is
Thanos says it's his soul gym the gym on
his forehead we didn't see that that the
champion initially says no that he's not
going to do this that somebody will find
him at some point or another and then
Thanos replies by saying that if that
happens if somebody does arrive they'll
remember who the champion is that he's
violent that he is an individual that
lists for warfare and they may very well
soon we just leave him there at this
point the champion surrenders his gem to
Thanos and tells Thanos said it never
functions anyway which again gives
credence to the statement of Thanos had
made at the beginning of the Thanos
quest that the individuals who wield
these gems simply don't know what
they're capable of at this point we see
that Thanos locks a tractor beam onto
the champion and begins to drag the
champion away and then what we see is
that he deposits the champion onto all
to another planet and when the champion
asks why does it he's doing this Thanos
simply says that their agreement was
that Thanos would take him to another
planet
he wouldn't wouldn't exactly that he
didn't didn't specify how he would be
transported to that planet at this point
we see Thanos really looking over the
gems looking over the fact that he has
gained the soul Jim which again allows
total control over a sentient Souls and
the power Jim which as we'll see in the
next portion of the comic where we
discussed the Gardner will be the
foundation for all of the other gems at
this point we transition to the Gardner
and again the Gardner is one of the
elders of the universe meaning that he
is one of a handful of individuals who
are the last remember remaining members
of their race and for the most part
while this comic or this portion of the
comic actually has no real combat I
would go as far as to say that it is
probably one of the best written
segments of the Thanos quest if not one
of the most interesting written segments
of Marvel Comics which again is simply a
testament to how great of a writer jim
Starlin is what we see is a Thanos
discussing talking to us about how the
garden of the Gardner is a beautiful
place how it is a gorgeous place is a
very well developed area and that the
Gardner realizes that Thanos is there to
capture his capture his soul Jim what we
see is that the gardener in Thanos begin
to go on a walk of sorts the the
gardener takes relish and the fact that
fan oohs is able to appreciate his
garden he's able to appreciate the work
that has been put in it and then we see
the Thanos ask the gardener why it was
that he had left the elders of the
universe why he had left this sort of I
guess loosely tied group and what we see
the gardener saying is that the elders
of the universe had sought power that
was their own real motivation they had
simply just sought power and once they
gained power they want they had a less
for more power but all he ever really
wanted to do was to simply tend his
garden and that once he was able to do
that once he was able to gain his his
soul Jim it allowed him the ability to
manipulate his garden which of course he
went back to we also see that he tells
Thanos that because he is able to
capture because he does have a soul Jim
that his garden is able to bloom more
beautifully than has ever been done and
again we're not really given any
indication as to whether or not the
gardener realizes that he's the one
doing this although
we'll learn at the end of the comic that
it is the infinity gym or the soul gym
that's causing this and not necessarily
the powers of the gardener from here we
see that the the gardener and Thanos
begin to stare each other down and this
is very reminiscent of a Kurosawa film
an old samurai film where we see two
opposing forces two enemies who for the
most part have respect for one another
but have contradicting ideas stare each
other down in this sort of I guess
ultimatum kind of scenario and this is
when we learned that the Gardner is
aware that Thanos is here to take his
soul Jim and Benes tells the Gardner
that the reason for this is because he
needs to further his own schemes and the
gardener replies if these schemes are
more important than the gardeners garden
Dano says yes he says that he cannot his
love for mistress death cannot be denied
and the gardener tells him that he
cannot give up his soul Jim without a
fight that this simply just cannot
happen and so Thanos begins to not
necessarily beg with the gardener but to
plead with him to simply say I ask that
you give up your gym that you don't make
me fight you and so um we see that the
gardener rejects this the gardener says
that that's not going to happen that he
is going to have to put up a fight and
we also see the gardener recognizes that
Thanos does have two of the six infinity
gems he has the sole Jim and he has the
power Jim which makes him a very
formidable foe and somebody that the
gardener most likely will not be able to
beat but then we see that again data
says that he has no wish to harm him he
has no wish to harm the gardener and
that his intention here is to simply
just acquire his Jim at this point we
see that the gardener attempts to use
his abilities to control his garden to
ensnare Thanos and again the fan of
simply just indicates us just
demonstrates to us his power and being
able to destroy the the garden or being
able to destroy the the trap that has
been ensnared around him at this point
we see that o is giving us this
explanation of the gardener and what we
see is that Thanos tells us that the
Infinity stones the infinity gems may
very well predate time not only that the
infinity gems may very well be the
cornerstone of all creation that because
each gem represents some facet of
creation that the gems themselves are
the source of power for these various
forms of creation and that again that
with all of the gyms combined that all
actuality all all reality can simply be
controlled what we see him doing is
giving us again another explanation of
the two gyms that he has he tells us
that Warlocks gym is the key to
controlling all of the the souls of
sentient life we see him tell us that
the power gym is the foundation the
power gym is what is able to power the
rest of the gyms due to its it's
infinite power and then we see that
Thanos tells us that the gym that was in
possession of the of the the Gardner was
the time gym and he tells us that the
reason why the Gardner was able to
manipulate his garden in such a way was
because he was able to use the time gym
to begin the process of growing his
garden and then manipulate time to speed
his garden up to the point where the
plants and the various life were able to
grow to their to their adult phase or to
their fullest and then he effectively
froze them in time so that would never
actually wilt but then we see that what
it actually happened here is that while
Thanos is giving us this explanation
that the gardener is in fact dead the
gardener was killed and Thanos was able
to do this by using the power gym to
effectively speed up the power or to
augment the power of the gardeners
garden in order to to move the garden
beyond the gardeners control to the
point that he couldn't stop it from
overtaking his body and in fact this is
somewhat of a haunting image if you if
you stare at it long enough with that
being said I'm gonna go ahead and bring
this video to an end hope you guys
enjoyed it if you did let me know and I
will catch you guys later peace
so the Thanos quest is an essential read
for anybody looking to get into the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline and
especially with the current set of
events that we see in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now there's a couple
reasons for this the first reason is
because this gives us an introduction to
how it is that Thanos gains the infinity
gems and we'll see that as the comic
progresses we'll first see them so as we
continue our discussion on the Pharaohs
quest what we need to do is rehash what
has happened so far and the reason why
is because moving forward the next
videos are going to be very fast because
there's going to be quite a bit
happening in a short amount of time just
because we're beginning this fast build
up to the Infinity Gauntlet proper
so at this point Santos has three of the
six infinity gems the first infinity gem
that was captured was the Green soul Jim
that was captured from the in-betweener
and this allows its wielder to
manipulate all facets of the soul the
wielder can corrupt souls the wielder
can bring souls back from the dead the
wielder can do a multitude of things it
has total control over the concept of
the soul the second Infinity Jim that
was captured was the red power Jim and
this was captured from the champion and
this allows its wielder to manipulate
all facets of power and in fact gives
its wielder total omnipotence meaning
they have absolute power within the
universe in addition this soul Jim or
this infinity Jim is very important
because this is the basis this is the
foundation for the rest of the gems this
allows the rest of the gems to reach
their full potential by drawing off the
unlimited power of the power Jim now the
other thing that I would like you guys
to pay very close attention to is that
while these gems have power while they
have incredible power all their own they
work best when they're in tandem they
work best when they're working together
now the third Jim and the Jim that was
last captured is that the orange time
Jim and this was captured from the
Gardner and this allows its wielder to
manipulate all facets of time they can
travel into the past into the present
and into the future and to send
individuals to each of these locations
in addition they grants total
omniscience meaning that its wielder can
know everything that has happened is
happening or will happen within the
universe now as we continue with our
story on the Pharaohs quest we see that
we're meeting up with a collector and
Thanos gives us a brief explanation of
the collector in the Marvel Universe
Thanos simply tells us that his name is
exactly what it sounds like that he
simply collects things he collects
people he collects organisms he collects
anything that he finds to be very rare
or very interesting or very powerful in
addition what we also see is that this
is an obsession for the collector that
unlike the Grandmaster who enjoys games
of chance or the champion who enjoys
conquest and power or the gardener who
simply just wants him to live in peace
that the collector has a drive to use
his power to collect anything that he
finds to be interesting what we also see
here is that the collector is waiting on
a message from Thanos
and when we see fan OHS communicating
with the collector when he first
contacts a collector the annals asked
the collector if he knows why he's
contacting him and the collector says
yes the collector says that he's aware
that Thanos is pursuing his infinity gym
and the collector has been monitoring
Thanos since his first encounter with
the champion from here we see fan OHS
again display his honorable side where
he tells the collector he has no
interest in destroying him but he has no
interest in killing him he simply just
wants his gym in addition he plays on
the desire of the collector to collect
things by telling the collector that he
has or will be coming into possession of
a very rare item something that is
one-of-a-kind and something that he's
willing to trade the collectors infinity
gem for now what we also see here is
Santos saying that this may have been a
little bit of a gamble here this may
have been a little bit dangerous and the
reason why is because it's very possible
or most likely that the collector
doesn't know the the abilities of his
gym because if he did then the results
would be very apparent and so theta says
by telling the collector that he's
willing to trade something for his gym
the collector may investigate the
properties of his gym and by doing so
discover what it is that he's gyms
capable of but that oh simply says this
is worth the risk that sometimes in
order to gain absolute victory you have
to take some sort of some sort of risk
and he effectively tells us nothing
ventured nothing gained from here we see
Fano simply just waiting and daños
waiting to see what happens if the
collector is able to discover the power
of his gym then Thanos will be able to
see the results if the collector is
unable to discover the power of his gym
then Thanos will not see the results and
what we see is that nothing happens
nothing takes place nothing to indicate
to Thanos that the collector has
discovered what it is at his gyms
capable of and so from here we see Fano
setting laying out coordinates to travel
to what's what appears to be the
location of an elder of the universe
called the runner and so what we see is
a Thanos teleports away and he teleports
to the locations of where the runner is
supposed to be but what he arrives the
runners nowhere to be found at this
point we see the Thanos ship his
teleportation of ice begins to
effectively disintegrate and then at
this point we see that something is
passing through his ship and
is ineffective destroying it the runner
makes him sore he appears to Thanos and
he tells Thanos that that he amazes
himself with how fast he's able to
travel and Thanos again begins to play
on the the bravado that the runner is
displaying here and again this is
something that I've hope you noticed the
Thanos never goes into the plan of
capturing an infinity gym without having
everything laid out beforehand and so
what we'll see as the story progresses
is that the runner will effectively fall
right into the trap if Thanos has set
the same way that we saw a champion fall
into the trap that was set by Thanos
what we see is that the runner is able
to recognize his ability to move so fast
due to the fact that he's drawing on the
powers of his infinity gym now he
doesn't realize what the infinity gems
capable of he simply just realizes that
it does have power because the Grand
Master had warned him that Thanos would
be coming for his infinity gym and so
it's somewhere along the line the runner
began investigating its properties what
we see here is that the runner is able
to move at incredible speed he's able to
exceed the speed of light and in fact
he's able to exceed the speed of thought
at this point we see fan oohs
questioning this Thanos asked him are
you really the fastest thing in the
universe and if you are then prove it
and so we see that the runner is moving
incredibly fast moving so fast in fact
that he appears to be in multiple places
at the same time speaking simultaneously
from here we again see that the runner
is displaying this vast bravado he's
very arrogant in his abilities and that
he boasts the fact that Thanos would be
able to do nothing to stop him Thanos is
unable to do anything to to keep him
from effectively getting away if he
chose to at this point we see that the
runner effectively threatens Thanos he
tells Thanos either tell me what it is
that you're here for tell me why it is
that you're capturing the gems or I'm
going to use my speed to kill you and so
what we see is that Thanos begins to
explain the origins of the soul gems
which i think is something that many of
you will find very very interesting
Thanos tells us that the infinity gems
are something that had been a secret
that no one had really known about for
billions of years and that while
individuals had possession
of the soul gems they never really knew
what they were capable of Thanos tells
us that at one point in time the
infinity gems were a single entity they
were a single being that had limitless
power and that this being was the only
thing in the universe and that the
problem is that because it was the only
thing because it had power because it
had a emotion because it had sentience
that it recognized that there was really
nothing for it there was really nothing
for it to do
there was no purpose in its life and so
it had an effect so we just existed
forever it existed alone and so it
filled this extreme amount of loneliness
and so as a result it self-destructed it
effectively killed itself and what it
did it dispersed itself among the six
infinity gems that were spread
throughout the universe and so once
these gems are brought together Thanos
was going to be able to utilize them to
effectively make himself an equal to
mistress death and to sit next to
mistress death as her mate in a so to
speak and so what we see is that the
runner begins to boast the runner says
that his that he's effectively going to
kill Thanos and that the secrets of the
infinity gems are his alone no one else
will know what the gems are capable of
that ohs tells the runner that he's a
fool that the only option that had been
given to him by the Grand Master was to
run and that he should have listened to
the Grand Master because the Grand
Master is probably the wisest and most
likely the most powerful of all the
elders of the universe and that running
was the only thing that could have saved
the runner from Thanos at this point we
see that Thanos again begins to taut the
runner and says that the runner instead
of listening to to the Grand Master
chose to boast he chose to be arrogant
and so instead of taking the intelligent
route instead of running that he simply
stayed and so Thanos tells the runner
that not all weapons that exists are
massive not all weapons are huge that
some of the most dangerous weapons are
some of the smallest things that appear
to be harmless and so what we see is
that Thanos explains to the runner that
he was in effect manipulating space but
he wasn't running at super speed that he
was more or less creating wormholes that
he would subconsciously desire to be
somewhere and before his conscious
mine caught up to it he would be there
which was in effect manipulating space
itself and which one we learned that the
runner is in possession of the space gym
from here we see that what Thanos had
done here as he was conversing with a
runner was manipulate time and that he
had in effect aged the runner by a
million years and by doing so put the
runner in such a position to where he
was simply just people there was nothing
he could do to escape Thanos and so
Thanos takes his soul gym away and again
what we see Fanus do is manipulate time
once more which brings us into the
second part of Thanos his plan the rare
item that Thanos had intended to barter
with the collector was the runner
himself
and so we see vanos convert the runner
into a child into a baby and from here
we see fan oohs tell the runner that
he's going to take him to visit the
collector at this point we see Pharaoh's
transport to the lair of the collector
and the collector had been lying in wait
the collector had intended to destroy
Thanos when he first arrived but of
course Thanos having predicted this
transports directly inside of the lair
of the collector at this point he
presents the runner to the collector and
tells a collector he will trade the
collector's infinity gym for the runner
and again this is something that the
collector is willing to do because the
runner is the last of his race with him
being an elder of the universe and so
there will never be another thing like
him he is in fact one of the most rare
items to have ever existed in the Marvel
Universe and so what we see is that the
the runner leads I'm sorry the collector
leads pharaohs to various places to to a
particular location where he's going to
in effect house the the runner and what
we see is that Thanos hands the runner
over to the collector and in turn the
collector hands his infinity gym over to
Thanos and so what we see is that as
Thanos takes the Infinity gym and begins
to walk away Thanos tells the collector
that the controller I'm sorry that the
infinity gym that the collector had was
the reality gym it was the ability to
manipulate all facets of reality but
because the collector had never used the
gym he had simply kept a store he never
drew on its power it had simply just
been there but the fact that the
collector had that kind of power in his
possession
and is something that the collector
laments the fact that he had just never
quite realized it at this point we see
Thanos demonstrating the power of the
reality Jim and begins warping the
fabric of all reality within the lair of
the collector and what we see is that
multiple facets of his reality or simply
just twisted and turn they're turned
they're intertwined to the point where
the mind of the collector just can't
handle it what we see is that the
collector is shocked by the fact that he
had such power that even this a slight
demonstration of the power of the
reality Jim was vast and it was
incredible
and he feels uh disheartened by the fact
that he had just never realized it what
we see is that that the collector gives
a warning to Thanos the collector tells
the TEL stano's that the Grandmaster
will be a far more difficult challenge
but we also see if Thanos taunting the
collector and telling the collector that
dispel or the the the I guess effect
that he had put on the runner to
transform him into a baby was temporary
and what we see is that the fan oh I'm
sorry that the runner transforms back
into a full-sized adult again at this
point we see that the runner and the
collector begin to fight one another as
as the runner is angry at the fact that
the collector had intended to to
imprison him forever and we see that the
last remaining individual the last
person the individual monitoring this
conflict is the Grandmaster who in
effect is the greatest strategist and
quite possibly the greatest mind and the
history of the Marvel Universe which
tells us that the last and final gym
that Thanos needs to collect is the mind
gym with that being said I'm going to go
ahead and ring this video to an end and
what we'll do when we pick up in the
next videos we will pick up with the
conflict between fan oohs and the
Grandmaster
over a game that's been created to
capture the mind gym and we'll also see
the fallout we'll see the ramifications
of what happens as Thanos captures all
of the gyms creates the Infinity
Gauntlet and ultimately
to the Infinity Gauntlet storyline but
that being said I will catch you guys
later peace we see is that the gardener
in Thanos begin to go on a walk of
source the the gardener takes relish in
the fact that anis is able to appreciate
his garden he's able to appreciate the
work that has been put in it and then we
see the Thanos ask the gardener why it
was that he had left the elders of the
universe why he had left this sort of so
as we get into the final chapter of our
discussion on the Thanos quest what we
see here is that Thanos is going against
the Grand Master now the Grand Master
like all the other elders of the
universe is the last member of his own
race meaning that he's the only survivor
and as such he possesses a vast amount
of power but unlike the other elders of
the universe that exists for either
conquest in the case of the champion or
collecting things in the case of the
collector the Grand Master has developed
a keen aspect or a keen mind when it
comes to all games of chance especially
when it comes to the concept of game
theory now to break away from comic
books for a second game theory is a
concept that was brought about I believe
by John Nash and game theory is a
concept within the realm of psychology
sociology and mathematics where it
drives to determine what the most likely
decisions people will make if the
success of their decisions depends on
the decisions of others so for example
one of the more popular elements in game
theory is what's called the prisoner's
dilemma and this is a classic instance
and game theory whereby the success
again of an individual depends on the
decisions of other individuals so let's
say for example that bidding and Sal are
driving to comic-con in New York City
and along the way they choose to commit
a crime now let's say that they're
captured by the police and they're put
into a police station and they're put in
two different interrogation rooms let's
say for example that the police come to
Benny and they say Benny if you point a
finger at Sal and say Sal was the
mastermind then you'll go free you'll
serve zero years and Sal will serve ten
years however if both of you choose to
stay silent if you say nothing then
you'll serve two years
however if both you and Sal point the
finger at each other you'll both serve
three years now Sal is offered the exact
same deal so the question becomes what
does Benny or Sal do does Benny take the
risk of serving time serving 10 years in
prison by staying silent or serving two
years assuming that South chooses to
stay silent or does Benny go ahead and
point the finger at Sal and take the
risk of serving three years or the
possibility of serving zero years if Sal
chooses to stay silent and so this is
the concept this is the question of what
happens when people's decisions are
successful but only under the condition
that other individuals decisions are
taken into account and this is what the
Grandmaster has devoted his his
existence to this is what he's mastered
more or less over the years and he has
done this with virtually all facets of
society with virtually all civilizations
within the Marvel Universe so what we
see as we begin to open up into this
coming book is that Thanos and the
Grandmaster are of course approaching
one another and the Grandmaster is aware
of wife a gnosis fear he's aware of the
fact that Thanos has come here to
capture his infinity gym in addition we
also see the Grandmaster asking fan OHS
why it is or if they enosis interested
in the the design of this particular
game or what it is that he has to do in
order to gain the grandmasters infinity
gym fan who says that he doesn't really
care but that most likely the
Grandmaster is going to explain it
anyway which he does
the Grandmaster tells us that the
infinity gym that he holds is housed
within a pan-dimensional transporter
meaning that it is able to transport
between dimensions in addition he tells
us that there are several layers of
force fields that are designed to keep
the device from being tampered with in
addition what we see the Grandmaster
saying is that in the event that the the
shields are breached any one of the
shields are breached that the prep and
dimensional transporter will immediately
engage and it will begin transporting to
various unknown locations and it is
designed to do this endlessly and so
Thanos will never be able to locate
where this infinity gym is what we also
see is that Thanos will not be able to
trace this infinity gym because of the
fact
that the man dimensional transporter
itself will self-destruct
and so again there'll be no way for
Thanos to locate this what we also see
is that in in the event that the
grandmasters life signs come to an end
in the event that he is killed that the
again the device will begin to transport
the device will begin to teleport to
various locations but what we also see
here is that the grand master tells
Thanos that in the event that he loses
in their game that the transdimensional
transporter will shut down that it will
simply just stop functioning
if-then-else will be able to gain the
Infinity gem what we also see is that
the Grand Master says that this is going
to be a sort of mind game this is going
to be as he describes it a
quasi-military exercise on the mental
plane and that because he's putting up
his infinity gym the Thanos should put
up his five infinity gems at the very
least to find a way to make the game
more interesting and so what we see
pharaohs say is that this is fine that
he doesn't plan on losing and so we see
the Thanos creates a stasis field around
the infinity gems that will deactivate
in the event of his death what we also
see happening here is that as the game
commences as the game begins the Thanos
comes to the realization that the the
way was explained to him by the
Grandmaster the idea that a kill shot
well simply just in this simulation is
not true that this simulation is very
much real and that if a kill shot is is
hit or I guess if Thanos himself were
hit with a kill shot that it would in
fact kill him mentally that it would
result in his death in the real world
and so we see that this game has become
very real that this game is no longer a
simulation that it could literally
result in the death of either Thanos or
the Grandmaster and so what we see as
things progress Astana's explains to us
with a sort of mental discussion that
he's done this thousands and thousands
of times that he's very used to playing
in these high-stakes games and for the
most part he's trying to match wits with
the Grandmaster which for the most part
he seems to be able to do quite readily
but what we see as the comic as a story
continues is that Thanos is able to blow
a hole in one of the obelisks and hides
inside of it and as the Grandmaster
comes looking for him the Grandmaster
fails to realize that Thanos
inside of it and so what we see is that
the Grandmaster turns around to realize
that Thanos has him on guard that Thanos
is in effect going to kill him and this
is a little interesting here because I
think that a lot of us what we had
expected when we went into this story
and we were reading about the
Grandmaster who had one of the greatest
minds and the Marvel Comics going
against Thanos was that most likely
Santos would be defeated by the
Grandmaster the Grandmaster would at the
very least find some way to outthink him
but what we see here is that Thanos is
as we presume able to defeat him and
Thanos file fires the killing blow but
what we see as a smoke clears is that
the Grandmaster is alive and well the
Grandmaster is not dead and the
Grandmaster gives us an explanation he
tells us that in effect he cheated that
he sabotaged
thanassis soon because the stakes were
simply just too high for him to to do
anything less but what we also see here
is that the whole reason why the
Grandmaster did this in addition to the
stakes being so high is because he's
begun to learn the true potential of the
infinity gems and this is the reason why
he did not step in when Thanos was
pursuing the other elders of the
universe when he was killing them off
one by one and taking their gems he
wanted Thanos to defeat each of the
elders and then bring the gems to him so
that he could in turn to feed Thanos and
capture all the gems for himself what we
see is that Thanos is in case from this
kind of silicon material and the the
Grandmaster tells him that it should be
permeating throughout the entire body of
Thanos it should in effect be become
part of Thanos so that when he pushes
him over that Thanos dies but what we
see is that once the Animus is pushed
over that is revealed to us that Thanos
was a machine that this was not in fact
the real Thanos and this is the one
element the one cog in the wheel that
the the Grandmaster did not think of and
so what we see is that Thanos destroys
the device that the Grandmaster had been
using to exist on this mental claim and
so the Grandmaster is now stuck inside
of his own mind he's unable to escape
and so what we see here is that Thanos
due to the fact that the game more or
less interprets this as the Grandmaster
being defeated is
to gain the last infinity gym now what
we see after Thanos is able to gain last
infinity gym is that he begins to
celebrate he begins to relish in the
fact that he has absolute power within
the universe that he is virtually
unchallenged by anybody within this
reality but it's very important that we
distinguish this from the fact that
Thanos is all-powerful or godly powerful
because Thanos's ability to manipulate
reality his power within the Marvel
Universe is confined to this reality
this is something that we will actually
see play out during the thin or the
uranium Infinity Gauntlet storyline
proper and when we see infinity and
other other cosmic entities along with
eternity and whatnot appealing to the
Living Tribunal to bring an end to
Thanos as rain so what we see here is
that once the analyst has gained all the
infinity gems once he has possession of
the infinity gems he transports to the
lair of mistress death and what he
reveals to us here is that despite
having absolute power that he does not
wish to wield this absolute power to
control the universe as a whole that in
fact all he wanted by gaining this power
was to be an equal to mistress death he
wanted to be her mate to sit side by
side with her for the rest of eternity
but what we see here is that in fact
mistress death doesn't view Thanos as an
equal any longer she doesn't view Thanos
as somebody who is by her side instead
as her as as one of her minions Samus
calls it relates to him that Thanos is
above her that Thanos has many stations
above her and we learned this because
Thanos doesn't understand why mistress
death will not address him directly he
doesn't understand why she will not talk
to him using her own mouth instead she
continues to communicate through her
minions and again what her minions tell
us is that because he is her superior
because he has many stations above her
that it would be it would be out of
place for her to speak to him directly
that in effect she should have somebody
interpret for her just because he is so
powerful it's really more of an instance
of somebody it to me to address somebody
who
is above their class above their station
and so what we see is that Thanos
becomes outraged
Thanos lashes out and he destroys the
one of the minions of mistress death and
this again gives us an explanation this
is the lead-up to wife anise launches
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline because
what we see is that after all the
efforts that Dinos had gone through
after all his attempts to gain the
affections of mistress death and all the
power that he had gained the one thing
he could not do is to make mistress
death love him he could force her to
talk to him he could force her to speak
directly to him but in the end she would
not be doing it of her own accord and so
this is when we see the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline launching this is
when we see fan OHS going to great
lengths to demonstrate his love for
mistress death albeit in a perverse way
by killing half the life in the universe
with that being said we're gonna go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it and again this
is a build-up and I think that what you
guys will see with the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline is a very rich and very
detailed story as we see multiple
superheroes despite the fact that they
are entirely outclassed doing everything
they can to extent to attempt to stop
the power of Thanos where that being
said I will catch you guys later peace
Dennis tells us that at one point in
time the infinity gems were a single
entity they were a single being that had
limitless power and that this being was
the only thing in the universe
and that the problem is that because it
was the only thing because it had power
because it had a emotion because it had
sentience that it recognized that there
was really nothing for it there was
really nothing for it to do there was no
purpose in its life and so it had an
effect so they just existed forever it
existed along